this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app all the
babies use the cash app which is why
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store and now the cash card is more
powerful than ever with the cash apps
latest feature cash boost download the
cash app get your free cash card and
select your boost save money when you
swipe on stuff like coffee Chipotle
Shake Shack and more download the free
cash app for iOS or Android now the way
and all the babies are checking in and
we are listening main there are a few
tickets left to my show on Thursday and
then I'm coming to Hampton Beach New
Hampshire which i think is sold out and
Connecticut in Foxwoods we're doing the
casino and I have a late to the Late
Show they're still tickets left the
first show sold out so come on by
episode 75 congratulations and just one
day closer to get into that log cabin
that's that's it I I I'm in Los Angeles
now doing the podcast and I'm happy I've
been to home for a little bit I'm
enjoying it I don't know what I'm doing
for the 4th of July I'm a backyard is in
shambles I am I am making my I am
redoing my backyard because I'm taking
out the fake grass when I bought the
house there was fake grass and the guy
was like it's really cool because it's
called smart grass no fake grass is [ __ ]
grass it doesn't matter what you call it
you can call it genius grass it's a
piece of [ __ ] your dog [ __ ] on it and
then you got to [ __ ] scoop it up and
then hey wait what the [ __ ] how does it
get wash I wash itself it's if it
doesn't grow it sucks fake grass [ __ ]
sucks it's not smart grass it's dumb
grass it's [ __ ] grass okay
so I'm putting in stone
and I guess that's [ __ ] I don't know
but that's what I'm doing and of course
it's taking longer than it should of
course it's taking longer than it should
because they say it's gonna be done
Tuesday it's not gonna be done Tuesday
it's not gonna be done Saturday it's not
gonna be done next week of course it
takes long as you gotta call the city
permits you got to all the [ __ ] and
snowing as far anyway I'm taking the
grass out and LeBrons coming to LA first
thought I had about lebron coming to LA
was literally audibly I go like this ah
[ __ ] cuz the traffic it's gonna suck and
there's gonna be so many people who are
bandwagon errs but trying to get on they
want to get out they want to go to the
game now because they want to see LeBron
you are a [ __ ] Barracuda you see a
[ __ ] shiny necklace and you flock to
it you were a fish you were a CUDA
no dude oh you know what I know you know
what I don't go to Laker games now I
know I'm definitely not going to a Laker
game because I'm not going cuz I'm not
I'm not going just because some [ __ ]
new players there and and and now some
hot chicks are gonna be there and
they're gonna be trying to convince me
to go with their Instagram pictures god
damn mother [ __ ] with their Instagram
pictures right they're gonna be so much
watched Braun play they're gonna do that
with their [ __ ] titties out going to
the lake show don't say Lake show
it's the Lakers you call the
Diamondbacks d-backs get the [ __ ] out of
here
go shopping I don't I don't know you
know the first thing I thought of was
all for [ __ ] sake the goddamn traffic
that's what I thought that's how much
I'm sure somehow I have a kid out there
because that's what a dad would say oh
great
LeBron you hear them from the other room
great [ __ ] great now dad's mad what I
[ __ ] LeBron coming to LA you know
what that's gonna mean from [ __ ] 4:30
to 8:30 on [ __ ] Laker games you got
gonna be a you're not gonna be able to
go anywhere goddamn it and even though
I'm in LA I'm a New York accent god damn
it [ __ ] you LeBron
you're not gonna be able to go anywhere
for [ __ ] sake
goddamn it and just [ __ ] a white
shirt and boxers with those like what
are the remember what guys would wear
like suspenders with boxers what the
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] in like 1940 keep
their boxers up or no you know what I'm
thinking of the [ __ ] keeping their
socks up from the boxers in the bottom
of the how stupid was that [ __ ] thing
how old-fashioned can you be yeah but
dude LeBron and then Bron people are
gonna call him Bron and then people
gonna go home Bron Bron and then bronty
with the slam and then and then they're
gonna [ __ ] you know what he is he's
French to me LeBron it stands for the
Brawn LeBlanc that's how I'm saying his
name from now on oh my god a kid with
the Lakers got little lip balm also he's
got upside-down head I can't trust
somebody was up with upside-down head
with the [ __ ] beard hair longer than
the [ __ ] hair hair can't can't I
can't get into it do it it it makes me
flip your head upside down have the
[ __ ] longer hair on the hot top of
the head and then the [ __ ] cut you
know I just can't [ __ ] scream for
another guy and be like you know what
I'm saying I can't do that maybe that
means I'm a beta but I can't [ __ ]
scream for another guy Yasko a bunch of
guys that makes me feel [ __ ]
like I'm like I'm maybe it's a
shortcoming for me I'm like I'm doing my
own [ __ ] nobody's [ __ ] well they are
actually when I go out on stage I don't
know I don't like anybody that much you
know what I'm saying I don't like
anybody that much and I for sure don't
like a team that much there's some
[ __ ] on that team probably right how
about that guy who [ __ ] up the game
junior or whatever I can't do it
I can't like I don't know
also they're throwing a ball around I
know I did a bit on incorrigible about
this but I still feel that way go bran I
did just to see the Instagram pictures
that these [ __ ] idiot girls are gonna
take do it with their tits out favorite
place in LA the lake show and they're
gonna hashtag it so other [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] sporks guys will see it and follow
him and be like damn she's hot the lake
show the lake no you I knew LeBron was
gonna be in LA because the Lakers get
everybody like the [ __ ] goddamn
Yankees do I'm surprised that LeBron
didn't go to the Yankees that's what it
should that's what it would have been
that would have that wouldn't surprise
me if they were like LeBron signs 150
million dollar contract for one year
he's taking Wolf's the guys name Johnny
Damon spot was it the guy he was in and
I mean years ago right but he was a
Yankee right that's how much I know
about sports LeBron is playing with the
Yankees he is going to be playing right
field because that's where everybody who
sucks goes he is going to be playing
whatever did Jordan there's a
centerfield because right field can be
can make up for it and left field can
make up for it so he will be playing
centerfield the worst position and the
Yankees are paying him and he's going to
have to cut his beard because the
Yankees have a [ __ ] rule about long
hair or some stupid [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] organizations you know [ __ ] how
sports teams are called organizations
it's a game
I don't know man hey what's up with
Terry Crews what the [ __ ] is he doing
man somebody grabbed your [ __ ] ah what
are you doing putting on a suit
talking into a microphone about it what
are you doing
gone at a sip what are you doing trying
to [ __ ] gutter the Supreme Court I
don't know where he is
it's talking to Congress or some [ __ ] he
gave some speech on sexual assault and
it was about a producer that did it that
grabbed his [ __ ] now granted that
producer shouldn't do it that producers
a piece of [ __ ] but stop acting like
you're a survivor you know why there's
firemen you know why people have been in
tsunamis somebody grabbed your [ __ ] oh
you had a bad day a [ __ ] I had
somebody grab my [ __ ] violently and it
hurt now it was an old lady and it was
outside the comedy store look I love how
Terry Crews was like when he held my
genitals in my hand he held he while he
held my genitals in his hand was that he
held the power no he didn't you played
football ah dude smash him
oh he held your balls smash him what up
dude
if a guy grabbed my balls I don't care
if it's Jesus Christ you get Chris
smashed
you know how Hulk has Hulk smash I do
Chris smash I even if it's beat the [ __ ]
out of me then but dude you're not
grabbing my nut cells the lady why
weren't you you're a big powerful man
why didn't you what is this world a look
I I'm a I'm a Terry Crews fan man I like
Terry Crews I think that he's a funny
guy is good actor but if someone grabs
your [ __ ] hey Terry Crews smash um I
don't know some guy [ __ ] aren't you a
guy when you're a guy aren't you just
waiting for another guy to do some [ __ ]
to you
isn't that just kind of like what being
a guy's like when you're out in public
somebody bumps in here all right
[ __ ] here we go what the [ __ ]
you doing this guy just stood there ah
[Music]
aren't isn't that just what it is being
a guy I don't know
and I would how long ago was it two that
that happened was he already famous I
feel like y'all ready had some [ __ ]
poppin maybe not Terry Crews
police report on groping I don't know
when it was but what wait here it is
here it is two years ago he said and
that was in the 17 2017
I'd like he was already famous as [ __ ]
here he did the on that that movie with
all the other action movies stars in it
I don't know man
I mean sexual assaults no joke obviously
don't grab somebody's [ __ ] nuts
I imagine a guy grabbing your nuts and
not [ __ ] fighting him I don't know
maybe I wouldn't if the guy was super I
don't know I haven't been in that
situation or another guy grabbed my I
don't think I have one other guy grabbed
my nuts like that Wow ya know Hollywood
is has a [ __ ] huge power dynamic
problem obviously look at how everyone
seen I mean that guy's going to [ __ ]
they just said he could serve life in
jail huh what a piece of [ __ ] that guy
deserves it you know it's just uh Wow
imagine imagine being what did that's
you know that's the thing man here's the
here's the thing we in Hollywood I swear
to God I have this theory where if
you're a guy that's an alpha and you're
just cool quote-unquote your whole life
you're you have no reason to be a
[ __ ] because you just kind of were
always dude that kind of you know heard
yes and no and also got what he wanted
and what he didn't want
you know nobody gets what they want all
the time but you were a guy that just
kind of like you got to watch out for
the [ __ ] nerds like Harvey Weinstein
was a [ __ ] dork like he was a [ __ ]
dork you know he was look at him he
looks like a [ __ ] brick wall a puffy
brick wall and like and like when you
get power you got to be real [ __ ]
careful with guys like that
because then they're like no I got the
power
and you were and they and a lot of those
guys have use it they don't all abuse it
but these guys think that they can do
[ __ ] and get away with it because of the
fact that now they've got all this power
and they don't know how to wield that
power now I'm not saying that guys who
are quote unquote cool guys don't do bad
[ __ ] of course they do but there's
something about that revenge
[ __ ]
that is just like and you can tell who
these [ __ ] are man you can tell
who these [ __ ] are like I don't
know
look at look at like look at Chris
Hardwick you're telling me that now I
don't know where I fall on that whole
thing because I heard her story and then
I heard his story and it's like oh well
she cheated on him and tried to get back
with him and now you hear that and
you're like oh wait a minute
right after all that [ __ ] but you're
telling me Chris Hardwick doesn't look
like a guy that would be like I don't
want you hanging out with other guy
friends you're telling me he doesn't
look like that
he's a self-proclaimed nerd with now
power that's what he's going to do
unless he seriously tries to reflect on
himself and tries not to be that person
and is herself reflective person but why
would you be when you own the Internet
it's too easy and people wanted to go to
bat for him too because he was this like
beta that became an alpha you can't make
betas alphas it [ __ ] it up dude I was
watching this thing on YouTube about a
cuttlefish and there are these
cuttlefish and a cuttlefish is this ugly
looking [ __ ] fish no it's actually
not even a fish it's like a mollusk it's
the same thing as a clam right and the
mollusk the the the the the male
cuttlefish are big
and they and they hide and the male
cuttlefish are big and so they take the
female cuttlefish and they [ __ ] them
right now some of the the beta male
cuttlefish aren't big and so here's how
the male cuttlefish will [ __ ] the female
cuttlefish the female cuttlefish will go
under the male cuttlefish for like
protection and then the male cuttlefish
will [ __ ] the females because they're
protecting them some of the lesser the
the the smaller male cuttlefish don't
have a chance because they don't women
don't women the females they don't want
to go under the those guys because
there's not enough protection so the
male cuttlefish will disguise themselves
as female cuttlefish go under the male
cuttlefish and then [ __ ] the females
under there ah you're telling that
they're getting crafty [ __ ]
they're getting crafty dude these are
these beta [ __ ] out there these
are these Harvey Weinstein [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] dude that's what Harvey
Weinstein did he went under the real
[ __ ] alpha he found in a
backdoor way and he's pretending he's
this guy and he's and he's taking what
he wants it's the guy's fault but it's
also them you can't reward these dudes
for doing [ __ ] like that we can't put
the camp make betas alphas you can't do
it you can't do it I mean Donald Glover
is getting all in all sorts of trouble
now because he [ __ ] ripped that song
why the [ __ ] are you surprised about
that you put him on an untouchable
pedestal if if I say I don't like Donald
Glover people will just say I'm racist
that's [ __ ] crazy now I don't not
like Donald Glover I'm just giving the
example that's [ __ ] crazy the fact I
own oh he did that you can't make a beta
and alpha dude I've been in the same
room as Donald Glover like we made him
an alpha
you I don't know I don't know you can't
you can't you know we don't I get it we
don't live in the [ __ ] time we're the
biggest strongest male matters anymore
it just it doesn't and that's that's
good by the way because we've figured
out how to care can't your diseases you
know we can't care [ __ ] everything
but we can cure a lot of [ __ ] that's
because of smart beta ass [ __ ]
you know they're alphas in their field
but if if every if the [ __ ] hit the fan
and in nukes hit in nukes hit the world
and there were a few guys left those
guys get [ __ ] eaten and [ __ ] by the
alphas I mean dude I asked my buddy
who's a who's beta ish I was like you if
you if the whole world fought each other
everyone for themselves 7 billion people
in the world however many people what
place you'd think it coming
and he said the whole world I said yeah
every man for every man woman for
themselves I said every man for
themselves and he's like I don't know
maybe like 3 billion that area and I was
like well we got to figure half of them
are women right so you could probably
beat up almost all of the women right
and he was like ok yeah so he's like
what about you and I was like I think I
would come in a billion maybe a billion
too you know and he was like see you
think he beat up and best and kill six
billion people in this world before you
die and I would say maybe you know I
mean you got to take into account how
many [ __ ] first of all half of them
were women I could I maybe I can't beat
up every woman but like a lot of them so
that's half let's just say half okay so
seven point six billion people in the
world that halves it to three point
whatever eight a lot of them are our
babies
how many babies are there I mean let's
just say how many babies and then
elderly I could beat all of those them
up so a billion I mean how many al are
elderly and under 14 I cuz I bet there's
some 15 year olds that can beat the
living [ __ ] out of me
knowed it was probably a [ __ ]
fourteen-year-old Croatian out there
that can beat the [ __ ] out of me I bet
there's at an 11 year old Croatian that
could beat the [ __ ] no just beat the
[ __ ] out of me and walk out like he just
went to the supermarket like there was
no fight involved Croatians are [ __ ]
Jesus Christ dude the hardest guy I ever
[ __ ] sparred with was a Croatian it
was like wrestling a wall and that's
yeah so I would say a billion I would
come in and maybe I would get lucky a
lot of the time too I'm also probably
smarter than a lot of people so I would
maybe maybe a billion but like what once
you get to like the healthy places like
la I'm [ __ ]
I'd actually probably died way earlier
in LA but if I was in like Midwest City
Oklahoma I'd be although there are a lot
of big [ __ ] corn Husker guys out
there god I wonder where you know where
a probably a good place to be is if that
happens is like Portland OR Seattle with
a bunch of like you know tech guys and
like glasses-wearing dudes that are just
like really open about their feelings I
probably probably probably fare pretty
well there and by the way by the time
you know the bigger guys got to Portland
OR Seattle I could you know but yeah
that's that yeah cuz I would say
Vancouver or some [ __ ] but take out some
big [ __ ] Canadians man anyway well I
don't know what we were talking about
but you can't it's tough man when you
start rewarding these beta [ __ ]
you know there's just there's a pecking
order you can't act like there's nothing
[ __ ] I probably get heat for that but
I mean I guess it's all supposed to be
funny but maybe not maybe I'm being too
serious I'm just [ __ ] who knows
whatever [ __ ] it
I listened to the to the Drake album
which I liked actually I thought it was
better than his last few albums who
gives a [ __ ] what I think about a Drake
album and like it matters you know what
you know what drives me nuts too is that
like Drake or somebody or anybody any
artist will spend like years working on
something and then someone will be like
it's pretty good
like he [ __ ] [ __ ] so like I'm
basically doing the thing I hate like
I'm not trying to review the the I just
it drives me nuts when peoples and I say
I and I I said this and I think this but
like it drives me nuts when people say
what I'm gonna say but like yeah it was
better than his last two albums like
[ __ ] me who the [ __ ] am I to say I don't
know anything about the Drake lives this
[ __ ] you know anyway I but I did I
didn't like the [ __ ] last two albums
oh by the way it's okay to say a kanye
album sucks because he takes [ __ ]
seven days to do it so go [ __ ] yourself
with that eight days he admitted he
didn't write any lyrics or didn't even
have the song write any lyrics for eight
days before the album came out go [ __ ]
yourself you know and these [ __ ]
will just buy it it doesn't matter scoop
that he poop poop poop they don't give a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I listen to that Kanye
I'm and I was like all right so but the
Drake album is good man and I mean he
just makes good music and but like it's
so millennial you know I mean [ __ ]
forty five percent of it is about
Instagram like there's have you heard
the album's have you heard album he says
like oh yeah you like in pictures you
like my picture
like there's so many lines like that it
was like you unfollowed me and I follow
and you got mad because who I'm follow
in like a few a little of that is good
but there's like basically a song called
Instagram or some [ __ ] oh oh I saw the
photos you was tagged in Oh
people have to be talking about that by
the way about I was talking about
Instagram a lot him he talks about
Instagram so much on his album oh I like
your picture you like mine I want to
make a rap you know he should have done
he should have just made a song called
Instagram and then it would have been
yeah and then it would have been just
all taken care of all of those lines but
how about the fact that he's making that
die I thought this [ __ ] was corny as
[ __ ] actually he put up an Instagram
post where you can buy a scorpion jacket
and put your name on it like and say
executive produced by yet but it's not
executive produced by you well so what
does it mean why would you you can buy a
jacket and engrave it or whatever the
embroider it I City it and buy it for
$150 and you can just put your name on
it and it says exact imagine wearing a
[ __ ] jacket that says me measure me
buying a [ __ ] scorpion jacket Drake
jacket supporting Drake and about his
album that's fine but then in grey and
grow during it executive produced by
Chris D'Elia when I had nothing to do
with it except for streaming it
hat imagine even wearing that [ __ ]
jacket if you did executive produced the
album scorpion hey also I was listening
to the Drake album and I kept listening
to like 12 songs and then stopping it
and then starting it over again I had no
idea it was quote-unquote
a double album or whatever I didn't know
also there's no double albums anymore
because there's no CDs but B side a side
and B side there's no sides anymore
it's all streaming I had no idea and
then I heard [ __ ] ratchet happy
birthday and I was like huh have you
seen the [ __ ] video of DJ Khaled
dancing around - what was the [ __ ]
song uh not just go to the tracklist
it was that high that knows on the
second side night no not nice for what
in my in my feelings so buzzy huh in my
feelings and then he's dancing around
dude dj khaled is seven years old I
don't give a [ __ ] you know who he is
he's Jack that [ __ ] movie with with
Robin Williams where he grows too fast
and he's just like running around
dancing just so fat but so doesn't give
a [ __ ] and then oh man it was so funny
is like he does it makes me want to do
the Naenae and then it makes it in his
like or whatever dance this is called
and then he does the [ __ ] dance that
all the [ __ ] all the kids are doing that
[ __ ] that video kind of made me like dj
khaled though the guys just [ __ ] I
mean he's so annoying but also like it's
so American like he's just the
quintessential American dream
and then he just runs at the end of the
video i retweeted it but he just is like
he's
I was so bad his dancing he says um and
then he just runs the end of the video
he just runs who was a video recorder
who was recording this his wife his his
his wife that's just like doesn't want
to be doing this but it's like I mean my
life's amazing [ __ ] it
yeah or the little baby's videoing it
the little baby can't video [ __ ] also
can't produce an album how about that -
stop saying he's goddamn executive
producer own um he executive producer
scorpion you know what I guarantee I
guarantee [ __ ] DJ Khaled gets one of
those scorpion jets executive produced
by Asad Khalid for sure in an extra
extra extra extra small hmm I'm gonna do
these [ __ ] ads here is this it
okay how about post mates huh hmm I love
it I use it all the time as usual as
usual your stomach and the rest of your
life or at war you need to eat but you
can't stop what you're doing to deal
with it and the only fast things that
deliver are not what you want right well
we're changing that introducing post
mates the app that adds a delivery
option to your favorite restaurants
anywhere imagine getting anything you
want to eat delivered you don't have to
drive park or even talk on the phone to
order just download the app and order 24
hours a day 365 days a year
plus mates will bring what you want to
you within the hour you could even see
where your food is and track your driver
so you can watch it live and be like no
no take a left there take a left it's
fun for a limited time post mates is
giving you $100 of free delivery credit
for your first seven days to start your
free deliveries download the app today
and use code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 off $100
of free delivery credit for your first 7
days save the hassle get the food you
love fast at post mates with code
congrats I use post mates all the time
it's the only one I use when I you when
I tried other ones and it's it's
annoying post mates is great
square cache if you haven't heard we're
switching to the cache up by now you
know it's the number one ranked app in
finance and lets you do the most with
your money whether you want to pay
people back buy and sell Bitcoin deposit
your paycheck right into the app or
order a free custom cash card to spend
anywhere you like and now the cash cart
is more powerful than ever with cash
apps latest feature cash boost the cash
cards boost program lets you get instant
discounts every time you swipe your card
right now you can get a dollar off every
purchase you make at coffee shops across
the country when you pay with your cash
card and you know daddy loves coffee and
if your baby you drinking coffee and it
doesn't stop there I see discounts like
15% off at Chipotle I'm looking at it
right now
50% off at Shake Shack and more they're
rolling out new boosts for the cash card
constantly so follow with the cash app
on Instagram and Twitter to find out
what boosts are next you can get the
cash card and black debit card and if a
artistic you can design that card
yourself which is very cool you show us
are your designs on Twitter I've been
taking a look at them you buy and sell
Bitcoin and your paycheck is deposited
directly into the app and of course when
you download the cash app and enter
reward code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to x up Legal Defense Fund
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now yeah I I did a tweet about
guitar hero with a [ __ ] game guitar
hero
I don't even know it's probably still a
thing they probably have like you know
what they probably have you know what I
suppose the video games like it'll be a
big [ __ ] big popular hit and then you'll
forget about it and then you'll find out
in like Japan they have 47 versions of
it and now you can play guitar hero as
Blanca or Ryu but it was like a a video
game where you could play as a good god
it was the it was the worst stupidest
[ __ ] video game I've ever seen
I mean the the the they had rock band
and DJ hero I mean hitting literally all
you were doing was hitting a button when
a thing told you to hit the button play
the real guitar some people were so good
it's just learn the real guitar get pus
god these door cast [ __ ]
playing guitar and I wrote I did a tweet
what was it I just said you know there
we go I mean it's not working you know
what sucked that video game Guitar Hero
if you played that and we're good at it
you were a piece of [ __ ] person and it
got 20,000 likes okay now I didn't
expect that and then I wrote it is it is
just like play the real guitar instead
it's an actual skill and that leads to
more [ __ ] it's just like you know
then some [ __ ] says a hundred percent
on Killer Queen expert mode do it like
yeah okay I I just like you're hitting a
button went and I know that's kind of
what all video games are but not really
you can you can do other thing in other
video I don't like the games were to
tell you got to hit a button when it
says hit a button and that's that's all
Guitar Hero is it's just really fast and
colorful and it's really [ __ ] stupid
and people were so good at it and that's
dumb because play the real good but
people were so good at it and not good
at the guitar and didn't know how to
play the guitar that's ridiculous and I
and
so many people liked it and retweeted it
and then so many people were like oh you
just weren't good at it
you had no [ __ ] because I didn't play it
I don't even know if I ever tried it but
I saw it a lot
my roommates would play it when I was
younger and dude oh my god
Oh better pam-i-am
I think that was on it was that on it no
dude it was just like who knows but you
said this is it basically what it is huh
but so fast boom boom boom boom boom
you can't dork central you're imitating
something and as a matter of fact dorks
get good at the guitar to become cool
you're doing the dorkier vert you're
doing the dorky version of what a dork
does that's how [ __ ] sad your life is
if you're good at guitar hero you know
what I mean a dork is like how do I get
checks to get to pay attention to me and
then someone created a guitar and now
you've got these heroin-chic tattooed up
badass [ __ ] that can play
really well and get chicks and that's
awesome they figured out a skill but
you're doing what the dorky fake version
of what a dork does do the real thing
it's amazing actually
people just don't want to go outside
they just want to be in their home
imagine buying that little bitch-ass
guitar imagine going and picking that up
and then it was like rock band hero
where you had a [ __ ] guitar and then
drums and then a guy with a
[ __ ] bass in Anaheim harmonica it's
like yeah how the house is a [ __ ]
recording studio that doesn't record
[ __ ] and instead of actual instruments
you got toys I'd let you know what I
would love if rock band was around look
at these dorky-ass drums that you can
get for [ __ ] rock band ones red and
yellow and blue and green oh God
but like imagine if rock band was around
in the 80s how many non musicians there
would be that our musicians now like
Phil Collins maybe wouldn't have existed
because he would have just been like no
I just like to play [ __ ] hail to the
Queen on experiment now I don't know
[ __ ] I didn't Mike Genesis the group
it's too busy in me room press and read
when a TV told me to press read that's
so bad dude I would love it dude
you know there's probably so many people
that you know what thank god there's
probably so many people not making bad
music now because they've just got
hooked on Guitar Hero Thank You Guitar
Hero
thank you rock band don't isn't there a
DJ one what I that by the way know
nothing about that couldn't even if you
gave me five days to try and figure out
what that is and not use the internet I
wouldn't be able to do it I'd be at
square one for five days DJ a DJ isn't
even a real thing I mean unless you're
producing the music which is not what
that probably DJ band Rock [ __ ] DJ is
doing DJ Hero look at how stupid it is
look how [ __ ] dumb it is
look how much that [ __ ] the whole
thing's jerking around the little
bitch-ass toy just mm-hm
Derk off just go in your room and jerk
off DJ hero on expert dude
DJ DJing isn't even really a thing
due to what that's that that's the key
you do to do the thing to make a game
out of the thing that's already a game
is really it's really the thing isn't
that the [ __ ] truth though that's why
video games are so [ __ ] big but I was
but I guess Call of Duty are those like
that's mom you know a mock-up of how
real war is it's not that's not a game
I mean Call of Duty's a game obviously
but not war obviously but like a man
rock band I can't get over how dorky
that is I thought about that after I
tweeted it and for a good hour and a
half I was just thinking about how
[ __ ] dorky that is and I was laughing
by myself rolling around in my car still
laughing about it you know you
[ __ ] don't get it dude
I laughed by myself all day long I see
people in convertibles i laugh i I see a
guy wearing a [ __ ] stupid bandana and
sunglasses at the gym I laugh I laugh I
don't hide it I laugh I go next to him
cuz [ __ ] em dude if you're gonna wear
that you get the reactions nobody ever
comes up to me and says what are you
laughing at to that that blows my mind
guys being guys oh my god dude what's
that dude there's a [ __ ] soccer
player name some basic a sebacean well
that's funny one fire just pulled up a
guy who tweeted me so basic
Wow more than one people did it the cult
is strong man
the cult is strong Wow
I just can't uh alright what else we got
here I don't know did you guys see that
movie head were hereditary everyone's
flipping her out about hereditary did
you guys see it it it's we're getting to
the point where horror movies and you
know it kept my interest in all that
[ __ ] and we're just again to the point
where horror movies like are just like
doing the things that horror movies have
been doing like you like the like how
many times can it be interesting where
you think you see something dark and
then you turn it on and then there's the
guy's not there anymore or how many
times are they gonna do this shot were
the persons on the ceiling like this
looking backwards at the guy how many
times I get to that oh and uh oh and a
creepy kid again a creepy kid again only
this time it looked the kids face it
looks weird or something I don't know
what would the kids like it's a little
off-putting the face of the kid maybe I
shouldn't say that because it's a kid
really good acting in the movie though I
just like what what is up with the
[ __ ] horror movies just having a
creepy kid and then you got to [ __ ]
have the guy those are the scenes you
got to have you gotta have a creepy kid
and you gotta have the the scene where
something is in the dark and then you
turn it on and it's not there anymore
and not only does but yeah and not only
do you not notice does the does the
character not notice the character
thinks they noticed something and they
turn on the light and they see it's not
there and in their head they're like oh
it was nothing but us as audience
members knows we know that's that there
was a person there because it was there
and so it's like it doesn't make sense
because you would [ __ ] know do it
you wouldn't think you saw something but
also it wouldn't happen in real life
you'd [ __ ] if there was a person
there to be a person there
Hey but there were some freaky and scary
moments though but the way people are
flipping out about the movie is making
is like come on it I'm not saying it's
bad but come on it's got all the things
that horror movies would have and why is
the girl why is the lady mint make
miniatures what is that all about it I
didn't understand
maybe I'm the dummy by the way but there
was like no reason for that like she
literally was just the scary [ __ ] would
happen and then she'd just be like
painting a small house and setting up
stick-figure or dolls and one time she
was setting up a doll [ __ ] or holding
her titty and and feeding it to the the
daughter or something why I had nothing
to do with the movie it was just creepy
I guess like don't make [ __ ] creepy just
to be creepy I'm just getting to the
point I don't even want to see movies
anymore I just want to look at [ __ ]
instagrams of dogs seriously
dude I could stare at a dog like it's a
painting [ __ ] art I want to go to a
museum where there's just dogs around
and you just look at dogs and now I know
that that's a pet shelter but also it's
not I want to have the dogs but just
even pictures of dogs they're so good
man I followed this golden retriever
account on Instagram and it's on man I
watch that [ __ ] and it is on I watch it
like it's a [ __ ] I look at it like
people look at Salvador Dali paintings i
watch it like it's [ __ ] the show the
affair you know on Showtime never seen
that show god women love that show the
affair right women love shows about
cheating God women love shows about
cheating what is that right cuz guys are
usually the ones that cheat but what is
it about women that love shows about
cheating you know why it's because their
relationships most of the time all
relationships when they get older they
become
Excellus and girls won't cheat but guys
will but girls will like watch the shows
and be like I want that that's like
that's pretty funny actually like I mean
girls cheat too of course but not as
much I guess right I don't like when
guys are like oh yeah but do girls cheat
just as much as guys that no they don't
dude no they don't they don't even cheat
as close to as much as guys do guys have
all this [ __ ] sperm in their balls
and need to get it out you know girls
don't have anything to get out the girls
have to release one thing a month the
eggs guys have to release both guys got
calm guys on calm guys want to come guys
on come and then cut to the the Jeff the
of the [ __ ] blonde hair guy blinking
guys won't come all the time I'm doing
it on the video podcast it's a [ __ ] to
tell people listeners that I'm doing on
the video podcast I'm gonna start doing
that meme in real life [ __ ] that I'm
doing that meme in real life from now on
when somebody says someone we go got a
look at the video podcast for that
babies um I love I love looking at dogs
and you'll never take that away from me
dude you'll never take that away from me
I'll look at cute dogs and there are
some ugly [ __ ] dogs out there and I
will not look at those Afghan hounds are
you kidding me those dogs are so ugly
I'll tell them to the
face I'll look at a [ __ ] Afghan hound
and I'll say you're an ugly [ __ ] aren't
you you're an ugly [ __ ] dog an owner
would be upset I don't care don't get
afternoon Afghan out you did look ugly
as [ __ ] and then you try to style the
hair looks worse poodles are fine if you
cut it like a fun thing you [ __ ] up
the Bureau you congratulations got an
ugly dog how about when people try to
pretend oh but it's so ugly it's cute
nope ugly oh but I just love because
it's it's so no scares the [ __ ] out of
kids leave it I also I had a buddy it
that had a pet pig growing up and we
lived in [ __ ] la Kenyatta California
not you know what I mean
Montana where were they [ __ ] happy I
don't even know where they have pigs
Texas somewhere probably because of
bacon and they're so fat over there got
it so
to be a fat Texan you know with a big
cowboy hat and [ __ ] boots and a belt
buckle I don't even know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about anymore maybe I'm
devolve in here you wanna do some
questions
let's see some Twitter questions babies
I'm sweatin I'm not sweating all that
much I'll crank the air up that's why
this this I saw this actually John
Lindros at John Lindros one I was at a
deli and I ordered a pulled pork
sandwich without coleslaw the woman
working there kept trying to convince me
to get coleslaw even though I don't like
it and already asked for my sandwich
without it what would you do in this
situation I'll tell you exactly what I'd
do in this situation I would I would
look at the lady and I would say this is
exactly what I would do no joke no
nothing I'd say ma'am I I don't want
coleslaw and you keep saying I would I
like coleslaw and I don't want it so you
don't have to say that anymore that's
exactly what I would say to that lady
and people would be like whoa dick and
I'd be like no it's not dick it's dick
to keep asking somebody over and over
the same question when they already
answered as a matter of fact this happen
the other day when we was i I was I was
in I was getting almonds that's what I
was doing because I was so hungry I
walked from the comedy store over to the
two pink dot and I went to get almonds
and I got almonds and a topo Chico is
that what they call it they're so good
that's the best club soda and so I got
the all I got the almonds and the topo
Chico and I had nothing else and the guy
said you want a bag oh no first of all
he said he said something to me and I
didn't hear I said what'd you say I said
what'd you say to me and he said oh I
wasn't he said I wasn't talking back to
you I was just asking you a question
and I said yeah I just didn't hear what
you said so I was asking what you said
all good and then he said do you want to
back and I said oh no thanks and he said
you sure and I said by the way we got to
clean up are you sure
you don't need to ask you sure after
dumb [ __ ] like that you only like
life-changing [ __ ] do you need to ask
you you sure about do you want a bag no
you sure I just [ __ ] answered that
didn't I man okay but obviously I don't
do that in public cuz I understand it
you sure is a socially acceptable thing
you want a bag I said no thanks
he said you sure I said yeah no no
thanks and then he said you sure and I
forced myself not to say anything
because it was hard because I the
natural thing is to be like uh yeah yeah
I definitely don't need one you know a
nice person would just be like yeah I'm
all good even the third of fourth time
but I forced myself to not say anything
because I wanted him to feel how
uncomfortable it was what he was doing
so I'm not here to play any [ __ ]
games dude I'm here to get my topo Chico
and my [ __ ] six grams of protein
drives me nuts on the almonds it said on
the top of it six grams of protein like
that was a selling point like like we're
so health-conscious and pink dot hey you
need bro you need your protein go to
[ __ ] and go to get some almonds at a
pink dot so the guy said you sure and I
didn't and I didn't I didn't say
anything I wanted to say yeah again but
I didn't because I wanted him to stir in
the [ __ ] bed he made you did this
[ __ ] I think I just looked at
him and I didn't say [ __ ] how many times
I got an answer how many times I got an
answer I don't want to [ __ ] back one
maybe two not three this is funny the
silky way at the underscore silky
underscore way how about the people who
see LeBrons Laker contract and say 154
million I'm in the wrong business dude I
just don't like all the sayings you know
people that just say [ __ ] does it like
they would be a like even if they were a
professional basketball player how will
goddamn hard it is like some like desk
clerk
say it's shim [ __ ] like that I'm in the
wrong business like they try at life at
all and how hard it is to be in the NBA
period and then to be not only the best
player in the NBA but the best player of
all time arguably and to be like I got
if I'm in the wrong business oh really
at your [ __ ] desk you're a you work
at a hardware store you know the [ __ ]
nerve that's like these chicks that say
Elon Musk is husband material no [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] Instagram thought and
he's flying rockets to Mars oh yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah he should be so lucky to
get tagged in one of your [ __ ]
thought ass photos in one of your photos
where you're showing your ass crack and
your titties bunched up any bina cuz you
flew over there from a from a guy who
wishes he was Elon Musk also you're not
there right now you saved it to post
later to say to act like you still were
there which is definitely a Drake line I
know a girl who took a picture and
posted it later to act like she's still
there hey Drake you rapped about
Instagram too much on your new album I
mean dude here's another one
Cisco at the real Kisco and there's only
one Cisco buddy don't need to have the
real one Maddon some would be like yo is
that the [ __ ] first disco or the guy
who faked it what would you rather have
a shitty voice or a shitty laugh that's
a real good one man I gotta say having a
shitty voice [ __ ] sucks like just to
be a guy who like would talk like this
or something hey what you guys doing you
want to come over for a farm for a pool
day like no you know no we don't cuz
your [ __ ] ass voice but having a shitty
laugh let me tell you something at least
with a shitty voice
man it's crazy I've already thought
about dumb I've already thought about
this like I've already thought about
that I only have thought about dumb [ __ ]
in my life like I would never spend a
waking second on how how would you
better this world but I've definitely
thought of would I rather have it like
I've I definitely already have thoughts
on shitty voices and shitty laughs so
when you ask me something like this I
got banging the dang at a dang it dang
it a day in my head I'm going well I
know about this chank chank chank chank
chank here's what you know how eminem is
like he's like he just know he has a
database of what rhymes it's not that
he's like figuring out what rhymes on
the spot I already thought about this
[ __ ] cuz I think about things that are
nothing all day long okay would you
rather have a shitty voice well [ __ ]
have any shitty voice [ __ ] sucks
because nobody can take it seriously and
if you want to invite people to a pool
party you're in the instinct is no and
you can't get a lot of people at your
pool party if you have a shitty voice
unless you've built yourself a great
life and have a great house and you know
take good Instagram pictures or whatever
the [ __ ] but if you just have a shitty
voice and you're just some guy you can't
have anybody at your pool party cuz
imagine that do you want to come to my
pool party no man you can be talking
like that there well that's my voice
cool give me another address but if you
have a shitty laugh you know what you do
if you have a shitty laugh you ruin
everybody's good time that's what you do
having a shitty voice is fine because
you'd know what you're gonna get right
when you meet the guy but if you have a
shitty laugh and you're in a movie
theater watching Austin Powers or
whatever and all of a sudden you're that
[ __ ] that's like ah
[Music]
you [ __ ] 350 people in the ass you
[ __ ] him out of 1250 yeah there are
people who laugh like that I've been in
rooms where people laugh I mean I've
been in obviously every night I'm in a
room where people are laughing saqqaq
[Laughter]
every night I'm staring at [ __ ]
hoards of people laughing its [ __ ]
I've been in the rooms where people are
just like yeah and I wanna [ __ ] I
want to ask him to leave but you can't
because that's the lab but some people
like lay into it those [ __ ]
that lay into their [ __ ] [ __ ]
laughs those people are the worst and
they just become the the show I think
I'd rather have a shitty voice cuz I
don't want to ruin people's good time
I'd rather not have the good time
because people don't want to hang out
with me because I have a shitty voice
but man you know what I wouldn't want
though a guy that has like a high voice
like that like would be awful dude if
you don't have a [ __ ] low voice as a
man it sucks a lot of girls won't like
you man and that that one was okay oh
that's a chick asking it actually that's
pretty funny that that yeah okay so oh
no this is a guy or a girl if it's a
girl it's an okay question it's a girl
okay so it's an okay question I think do
guys look at folk but you know the
answer though already do guys look at
photos of themselves and say damn my
dick looks good the way girls do about
their tits
Evan Claire well I mean they weigh less
you know I would never put I would I
would never think I don't think I've
ever looked at my [ __ ] area before
posting a picture but maybe some guys do
maybe gay guys because they wanted like
attract other gay guys but like women
don't really look as a general rule
women don't really look at [ __ ] areas
and think like gosh I gotta suck that
unless you're a complete [ __ ] mess
you know unless you're complete mass
unless you're
that was a real shitty - you alright
we're done
Square cash check out the new boost
rewards program get the cash app enter
rewards code congrats get $5 and give $5
- times up get it for iOS or Android now
don't load my download my app subscribe
to our YouTube channel the they come out
the videos coming out Tuesday or
Wednesday subscribe rate and review the
show it really helps us over there and
watch my specials on Netflix and then go
to we got stuff in the store we got a
bunch of shirts and merch it's all
stocked up so that's gonna go away soon
so go get that [ __ ] and all my tour is
up Chris D'Elia Chris D'Elia calm so go
check me out follow the leader and
thanks for listening my baby
[Music]